my project is to study in a differential
tumor microenvironment response to pda
one checkpoint inhibition which is type
of cancer immunotherapy
the main objective of this project is to
understand the mechanisms of failure in
non-responding patients by comparing
their tumor microenvironments to that of
responding patients when subjected to
this form of checkpoint inhibition
therapy
for an introduction to immune
checkpoints checkpoints inhibitory
molecules which receptors expressed by
an immune cell most commonly t cell and
that interact with the ligand which is
being expressed by an anticipation
presenting cell and this receptor ligand
interaction facilitates a signaling
pathway which is meant to restrict or to
check the activity of immune cells and
to prevent them from reacting against
cell cells however in the case of cancer
when the malignancy is caused by
transformation of cell cells this
actually facilitates further tumor
progression and it disarms or disrupts
antitumor immunity
one such example of an immune checkpoint
is programmed that one or pd1 whose core
receptor is expressed on the surface of
t cells and the ligand pdl1 is expressed
by an antigen presenting cell for
example cancer cell so this helium 1 pd
l1 interaction usually induces t cell
apoptosis which is program cell death or
it may induce t cell inactivation also
known as diesel energy and overall it
leads to a phenomenon known as diesel
exhaustion which is a point where the t
cells despite receiving sustained
antigenic signaling cannot mount an
immune response against the tumor and
hence they are in a state of exhaustion
so because this disrupts antitumor
immunity to restore immune function to
combat the signaling method there has
been the development of a certain immune
therapy which is known as immune
checkpoint blockade or immune checkpoint
inhibition
in this form of treatment monoclonal
antibodies are used as blockers or
inhibitors to block either the receptor
which is being expressed by the immune
cell or the ligand being expressed by
the apc in order to disrupt their
signaling
so in the study that i have chosen for
this project a pd1 blocker which is the
receptor blocker has been chosen known
as pembrolizumab so since this is the
receptor that is being blocked uh the
pembrolysomab drug is attacking or
targeting the t lymphocytes which are
expressing the spd-1 and not the cancer
cell itself
in the case of immune checkpoint
blocking immune checkpoint inhibition in
recent years has shown success in
several cancer times however there is
still a majority of patients who fail to
respond to this type of treatment
there can be several factors which
influence this kind of failure to
response and one such factor would be
the heterogeneous cell population of the
patient tumor microenvironment
in this project uh the tumor micro
environment cells including the tumor
cells the surrounding stromal immune and
epithelial cells are being taken into
consideration to understand the
mechanisms of resistance or failure to
respond
patients who have been selected in this
study are
cutaneous t cell lymphoma or ctcl
patients ctcl is a type of non-hodgkin's
lymphoma which originates in t
lymphocytes and although it is generally
curable or shows good prognosis in early
stages uh it is often overlooked or
under diagnosed because in the early
stages the symptoms are presented and
are often mistaken for eczema or
psoriasis uh hence the relative survival
of these patients actually worsens with
increasing stage
at which point it is difficult to treat
the cancer
one of the common characteristic
features of ctcl especially advanced
stages is a high upregulation of pd1 and
the pdpdl1 interaction and t cell
exhaustion
the data center have selected to carry
out this project is a high throughput
sequencing transcriptome data set uh it
has a collection of 64 samples taken
from 14 patients
out of which there are seven responding
patients and seven non-responding
patients
so each of these 64 samples corresponds
to a specific region of the tumor micro
environment which is infiltrated by
immune cells
and overall the two groups of patients
responders and non-responders have been
divided into pre-treatment and post
treatment so pre-treatment is before the
administration of the therapy which is
in which in this case is pembroke's oman
uh that is mentioned before is an
antipedia one molecule
uh and post treatment condition which is
after the administration of pembroke
these patients which have been selected
for this study and that i have taken in
this data set are actually the same
group of patients who were previously
enrolled in another trial using the same
anti pd1 molecule however that trial
failed to provide any
significant predictive biomarkers so uh
they have been taken again for another
analysis in this study
my main research objective is to
identify or determine the molecules and
pathways which are being upregulated or
downregulated in non-responding patients
and the reasons behind resistance to pd1
immune checkpoint inhibition treatment
in these ctcl patients
so the main objective was to first try
and predict uh the suitability of a
patient to a certain treatment approach
by first checking between the uh the
profiling of the tumor immune micro
environment between responding and
non-responding patients in pre-treatment
conditions that is before the uh therapy
has even been administered
uh the main aim here was to identify a
specific biomarker which might help us
to predict whether or not a patient
would be
would show favorable outcomes before
they are subject to the form of
treatment
to further confirm the results that we
see in the pre-treatment conditions uh
the next groups of analysis were taken
to compare between responding and
non-responding patients and
post-treatment conditions as well
followed up by a comparison between the
same group which is within the same
group of responders denoted by r and
within the same group of non-responders
denoted by nr uh by comparing their two
microenvironment profiles uh before and
after treatment
so all in all i have four groups here
that i have conducted analysis on in
order to understand how to gain uh in
gain insight into the type of biomarkers
which might be involved in the response
failure um when this form of pd1
inhibition is administered
all the methods that i used were
performed uh on the t bio server
platform and since the data that i had
selected was uh taken in raw read counts
the first step of my analysis was to
clean and filter these roarings after
which i then took them forward for the
next few steps of analysis
to filter the raw reads the first thing
i did was to use uh the an excel
function to remove any low expression
values or low expression genes for
example genes which have a zero
expression value across all samples so
in order to do so i filtered for all
genes which have um
sum of expression greater than equal to
10 and so from an original 56 000 genes
i now had a total of many 1943
after having gained these
set of genes i then log normalized these
samples by taking log 10 and
constructing the box and viscous plot in
order to identify whether there were any
outliers which were present in my data
set that i should remove before i
continue with my further analysis
on the box and riskers plot help me
identify these outliers in both
pretreatment and post treatment samples
which have been listed here in the box
on the right and after removing them i
had a total of 53 samples and 21 943
genes which i then took forward for
further analysis
so my first step of analysis was
exploratory analysis and to do so i used
principal component analysis or pca on
the tbio server platform by using the
pca algorithm or the pca pipeline which
is available
so in order to conduct pca uh which is
to
basically help in visualizing the
overall variation or segregation in my
samples
i took uh the raw rain counts and i log
normalized and then quantile normalized
them with a threshold of 5.0 and after
running pci removed any glaring outliers
to obtain my final pcs
uh
here the two graphs for my first two
groups of analysis that is pre-treatment
conditions responders versus
non-responders and post treatment
conditions responders versus
non-responders have been depicted
and here are the two graphs for uh only
responders free versus post treatment
and only non-responder group previously
post treatment have been depicted
so as can be seen from all the graphs
there was no clear separation or clear
segregation between the samples
many of the samples were clustered
together and so because it could not
give me any clear variation i then
needed to move on to the next step in
order to
gain a better insight into the actual
variation between the data
there might have been multiple reasons
due to which the pca did not give much
information about the data separation uh
one might be the fact my sample set was
actually very low for the individual
groups of analysis or it might be that
there were some changes uh that was seen
that were not uh showing up at the
transcriptomic level before and after
administration of treatment so the pcs
were not uh sufficient to for me to
understand this kind of variation
so i then moved on to the next step
which is to conduct a differential gene
expression analysis
and again i used a t-bio server to do so
where i used a dsec or the differential
expression pipeline and i used a dsec2
algorithm along with enrichment analysis
uh to understand the variation among the
data for each of my four groups
data that i uploaded was in rory and
counts and i divided my samples into two
groups while uploading them to the
desect pipeline my group a was my
control and my group b was the
experimental group
which is the group where i wanted to
check for the up regulation and down
regulation of different genes
so in the case of my first two groups of
analysis which is to check or to compare
between responders and non-responders
pre and post-treatment conditions i took
my non-responders as my group b because
i wanted to check for the type of genes
which are being differentially expressed
in the non-responding patients by taking
the responders as control and in my next
two groups of analysis which is to
compare within the same group before and
after treatment i took post treatment
conditions as my group b because i
wanted to see the changes in the tumor
micro environment after the treatment
has already been administered and i took
the pre-treatment conditions which is
before the treatment was administered as
my control
these were the parameters that i took
for conducting the dsec analysis and the
ph just in value threshold was taken as
0.05
now i will be discussing the results
that i obtained for each of my four
groups of analysis
so the first which is the main purpose
in the study that is to help in
predicting a biomarker of non-responding
patients before the administration of
treatment i compared between responders
and non-responders in pre-treatment
conditions and after having done so the
number of differentially expressed
significant genes that i obtained for
the non-responders group that was
statistically significant because they
had a p adjustment value of less than
0.05 was equal to 111 genes out of which
47 were upregulated and 64 were
downregulated
so from the volcano plot here uh the
main upregulated gene which aligns with
the purpose of the study was adgrl4
so adgrl4 also known as altd1 is an
example for gene whose expression has
been seen to create an immunosuppressive
microenvironment in the case of mouse
breast tumors however it has not been
seen in cutaneous t-cell lymphoma
immunosuppression would mean that it
would not only resist treatment but will
also induce or promote the
differentiation of deregulatory cells
and promote for the self tolerance
uh so adjural for altd one deletion in
glioma has actually seen to improve t
cell infiltration uh after penion
checkpoint block it was administered
so this might be a clue as to the
immunosuppression or the type of
resistance which is being seen in the
non-responders
among the down regulated genes that have
been uh that have come up on the volcano
plot the first was a knot too so not too
although normally involved in innate
immune response and inflammation and
response to bacterial infection also has
a role to play in the case of uh cancer
cells where several agonists or several
not to ligands are known to activate a
cytotoxicity of t cells which are
enriched in the tumor micro environment
so an inhibition or down regulation of
the knot two would be a possible reason
for a down regulation of the
cytotoxicity of the t cells besides pd1
signaling
other than this there were two other
genes which were anti-pop-tarting
factors that were also now regulated
as mentioned before pd1 pdl1 signaling
does induce t cell apoptosis or program
cell death as a mechanism of t cell
exhaustion to disarm or to uh to inhibit
anti-tumor immunity so the down
regulation of anti-apoptotic factors to
naturally promote apoptosis of the
immune cells
other than this there were several other
genes which were found to be upregulated
and down regulated from my dsec results
which have not shown up on the volcano
plot the most significant of which i
believe was hlag
that was upregulated so hlng is an
example of a more recently discovered
immune checkpoint and it interacts with
a specific receptor known as lil rb1 on
the t cells to induce t cell
inactivation or energy and t cell
apoptosis moreover hlg is actually seen
to be expressed in higher amounts at
advanced stages of cutaneous t cell
lymphoma and hlag also has a a higher or
a stronger immunosuppressive mechanism
as compared to other known checkpoint
inhibitors like pd1 because it affects a
larger number of immune cells
so hnng might be another uh novel immune
checkpoint which is being involved in
this non-responding uh tumor micro
environment which is causing an elevated
resistance to the treatment
other than hng expression uh there were
several genes which were associated with
um a process known as glycosamine of
light and degradation or gap degradation
uh which i will be discussing in the
next line when i will be showing the
english partners
there were
there were there was another group of
genes which were all responsible for
encoding several genes and transporters
and receptors involved in the gpcr
pathway so gpcr is important for cell
communication between the tumor cells
and the tumors trauma endothelial cells
blood vessels and immune cells of the
tumor microenvironment and gpcrs are
also known to promote tumor growth
dissemination and immune aviation and
tumor micro environment hence gpcr
signaling has actually become
a more recently identified target for
immunotherapy approaches as well
however the same time gpcrs are also
known for the ability to orchestrate
immune cell migration towards chemo
crying gradients which is often used to
predict a favorable response to
antipedia one treatment so further
research is uh required to understand
the exact role of the gpc pathway in
response resistance
among down regulating pathways the most
significant one was a protein tyrosine
kinase 6
so pkk6 is involved in another process
which is known as er bb signaling which
i will again explain
discuss in the next slide
so after having uh looked at my desect
results with the differential express
genes i then looked into the
significantly enriched pathways
and the most significantly enriched
pathways to be upregulated was uh
glycosaminoglycan degradation or gag
degradation
so glycosaminoglycans
are actually long chain polysaccharides
which consist of several repeating units
and several of the genes which were seen
uh to be involved in glycominoglycan
degradation are actually associated with
encoding transporters and proteins which
carry out gag degradation
so normally uh the the major classes of
gags which are relevant in cancer are
heparin sulphate
keratin sulfate and higher urine and
glycosaminoglycans are found enriched in
the extracellular matrix of tumors and
they're degraded by several gap
degrading enzymes most commonly matrix
metalloproteinases heparinase and
hyalurodinases
so since ecm degradation is an important
step in cancer metastasis gag
degradation and expression of these
enzymes actually contribute to human
progression by promoting invasion
angiogenesis and metastasis and the
ability of cancer cells to invade the
surrounding tissues greatly depends on
the expression of these enzymes moreover
the overexpression of glycosaminoglycan
degradation is known to promote tumor
metastasis which is a known contributing
factor to
therapeutic resistance uh however there
is a study which states that the
accumulation of glycosaminoglycans in
the tumor micro environment often
reduces the susceptibility to uh immune
checkpoint inhibition and that degrading
them especially higher leuven on
deviation would actually influence the
tumor cell sensitivity to immunotherapy
and that the degradation would
facilitate for the tumor cell exposure
to drugs
so in that case it would be a
contradictory finding because
degradation would then
increase our chances of seeing favorable
outcomes by increasing the
susceptibility to the immune checkpoint
inhibition um so this would be a
slightly ambiguous finding in this case
because it is unclear whether the over
expression or gag degradation enzymes is
contributing to further tumor
progression and resistance to therapy or
whether the degradation is actually a
contradictory finding in the case of
non-responding patients
uh in the downregulating pathways the
most significant one was erbb signaling
so er bb signaling uh is erbb is a
family of receptors uh well-known
receptors which includes hdr and egfr
and their main role is the activation of
oncogenic signaling promoting tumor
progression and hence the down
regulation the blockage will actually
make you microenvironment again more
susceptible to immune checkpoint
blockade and promote favorable treatment
response so again this would be a
contradictory finding
however there can be one possible
explanation for the down regulation the
signaling part with which is to
determine the type of cells which
expressed in the erbb receptors so uh
since erbb expression or oxygen
signaling is seen in the context of
signaling induced by tumor cells if they
are to be expressed by immune cells the
conditions might differ
for example there was a 20-20 study on
atherosclerosis which is a t-cell
mediated in vascular chronic
inflammatory disease
where the authors looked for egfr
expression on leukocytes specifically t
lymphocytes and not the cancer cells and
they observe that the blockade on
inhibition of egfr induced t cell
inactivation of t cell energy
since t cell inactivation or energy is
another phenomenon which is caused due
to a result of immunosuppression and
resistance to therapy the down
regulation of this pathway resulting in
t cell energy if expressed by leukocytes
immune cells would be a possible
explanation as to why we are seeing this
in non-responding patients
uh so
this would require further research
because since in cuping is t cell
lymphoma
both the malignant cells and the immune
infiltrating cells are t cells uh we
need to ascertain whether the er baby
signaling pathway is being induced by
the immune cells or by the militant
cells
other than this um
under the keg enriched pathways th17
differentiation was observed uh so th17
differentiation is often seen
co-expressed alongside pdl-1 signaling
however il-17 was not uh did not show up
in these results
uh th17 differentiation is known to
differentiate to give cytokines like
il-17 which is a signaling pathway that
is strongly associated with um pd1 pdl1
signaling uh and this may be supported
by the results that i received in the
next few groups of analysis
so my next group was to compare between
responders and non-responders in the
post-treatment condition and here there
was only one differential expressed
significant gene uh this one gene was
hlg and was seen to be upregulated which
would further verify the results that we
saw in the pre-treatment conditions that
hlg seems to be associated with the uh
failure or the resistance to response
in the keg english pathways uh the two
major pathways to be upregulated were
il17 and tnf
so here il17 signaling pathway seems to
be significantly activated and il17
signaling is known to increase pdl1
expression and it is known to also
promote resistance to antipd1 therapy uh
studies have shown that blocking the
il-17a signaling pathway has actually
seemed to improve the efficacy of
anti-pd1 therapy uh however this has
been observed in colorectal cancer and
lung cancer and not yet in ctcl
in ctcl cancer cell lines however the um
jack stack iii pathway promotes the
secretion of il-70 and leads to further
immunosuppression so this might be an
important pathway to look into in the
case of non-responders
other than this dna signaling was also
seen to be upregulated so tnf alpha
signaling in ctcl is known to induce an
immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment
through macrophage polarization and stat
mediated pd1 regulation and in melanoma
the tnf blocking has been observed to
prevent antipd-1 induced t cell
lymphocyte cell death so the overcoming
on the reversal of resistance to
anti-pd1 therapy may be achieved by tnf
glocken because tnf expression can
inhibit anti-tumor immune responses by
directly regulating the immune cell in
the tumor microenvironment
since tnf blockade has seen or has been
observed to show successful
overcoming of resistance to anti-pd1
therapy in melanoma uh the same might be
further studied in the case of cutaneous
t cell lymphoma
next protein they compare between was
for the responders only before and after
treatment uh as expected they had the
highest number of differentially
expressed genes which was 269 out of
which 83 were upregulated and 186 were
down regulated
among the significant enriched pathways
uh one interesting observation was the
fact that ph 17 cell differentiation was
activated here just like they were in
the case of non-responding
non-responders in the pre-treatment
conditions however despite a17 being
activated the il-17 signaling pathway
was blocked
uh since it has been seen at il17
blockade or il17 inhibition has actually
seemed to improve the therapeutic
outcomes this might be a clue as to the
fact that il-17 is indeed associated
with response resistance or failure to
response and it's suppressing this
pathway leads to favorable therapeutic
outcomes
and the last grouping i compared between
was for non-responders only pre versus
post treatment conditions here again
there were very few uh differentially
expressed genes uh only three out of
which one significant gene to be
upregulating was a tnf receptor known as
tnf rsf9
um dnf signaling again might be included
or might be associated with this kind of
result
other than this there was nothing
significant it was observed in the keg
enrichment
so to conclude i would like to um again
illustrate or to highlight the role that
hlag might play in the case of um pd1
checkpoint inhibition therapy in
cutaneous t cell lymphoma uh already it
is expressed or it is associated with
advanced stages of ctcl and since its
expression by interacting with its
receptors on t cells is known to induce
a very strong immunosuppression and to
also inhibit t cell proliferation and to
inhibit cell cytotoxicity and to
inactivate t cells this might be another
checkpoint that needs to be looked into
in the case of a cutaneous t cell
lymphoma
perhaps in the case of combination
therapy of hlag as well as pd1 blockers
other than this another
important observation would be the role
of th17 differentiation in il-17 il-17
signaling was seen to be activated in
the non-responding patient's post
treatment
um
and despite th17 differentiation in the
responders post-treatment
signaling was seen to be blocked this
might be an important clue as to the
association of il17 with the resistance
to the immune checkpoint broken
and lastly uh there are some results
which are in contradiction
um with the hypothesis of the study
which is the fact that that degradation
as mentioned
may or may not uh be associated with
this uh the favorable outcome of this
form of therapy because while the
overexpression of its enzymes may
facilitate further tumor
further resistance to therapy uh the
degradation might also increase the
access of the checkpoint inhibitors as
seen in some studies uh so this would
probably require further research on the
larger sample set to understand why they
are being upregulated in the case of
non-responding patients
other than this erbb signaling is uh
classically known to be associated with
oncogenic signaling and hence uh its
downregulation
being seen in non-responding patients
would
be
in in contradiction to the purpose of
the study uh however again it is
important to um important to certain
whether they're being expressed by the
malignant t cells or by the immune
infiltrating t cells um
and as has been seen that blockade in
deukocyte is known to induce t-cell
inactivation which would uh match the
hypothesis that um the immune checkpoint
inhibition uh therapy is often resisted
due to a sustain inactivation of the t
cells so again this would require
further research and lastly uh in the
results that i obtained for the
responding patients before and after
treatment i noticed that there were
several tnf receptors which are also
upregulated and are involved in dns
signaling however tnf itself has a quite
paradoxical roles in cancer and may have
both proteomerogenic and
anti-tumor effects and in the case of
cutaneous uh t cell lymphoma and in the
case of immune cell activation uh tumor
the tumor necrosis factor or tnf
signaling
may be associated with both immune
evasion as well as the facilitation of
antitumor immunity so again further
research would help us to
clarify the role of tnf in cdcl
and thank you